samstag wird es eng so heißt es in
einigen medien wie zum beispiel bei
bild.de die sprache ist von dem
asteroiden mit der bezeichnung 1999 kw
vier nasa berechnungen zufolge wird er
in der nacht zu sonntag in einer
entfernung von nur rund fünf millionen
kilometern an der erde vorbeifliegen das
besondere der es so ist wenn einem
durchmesser von immensen 1,3 kilometern
wird von einem eigenen etwa 500 meter
großen mond umkreist bei diesem doppel
brocken handelt es sich um den größten
der uns bis zum jahr 2027 so nahe kommt
klicks um science-fiction
hier gibt es täglich spannende science
videos abonniert den kanal nur dann
verpasst er nichts herzlich willkommen
die nasa stufte ihn hast du ihn 1999 kw
4 als ein potenziell gefährliches objekt
ein denn es handelt sich um einen
sogenannten erdnahen asteroiden der die
erdbahn kreuzen und im mai 1999 entdeckt
wurde und zwar vom lincoln ihres estate
research
das ist ein projekt des massachusetts
institute of technology mit dem alle
erdnahen asteroiden identifiziert werden
sollten seine flugbahn wird seit seiner
entdeckung ganz genau überwacht 188 tage
braucht er für einen umlauf um die sonne
und dabei kommt er uns immer mal wieder
ziemlich nahe
der doppel brocken besteht aus einem
rund 1,3 kilometer großen asteroiden der
alle 17 stunden einmal von einem eigenen
rund 500 meter großen mond umkreist wird
doch viel mehr wissen experten und
expertinnen nicht über diesen kleinen
begleiter von 1999 kw 4 beispielsweise
ist unklar ob es sich bei dem kleineren
begleiter um ein trümmerstück vom haupt
hast du jeden handelt oder ob er einst
eingefangen wurde
in der fachsprache ist auf jeden fall
von einem binären system gerät also mit
zwei teilen
doch auch die rotation und die form von
1999 kw 4 selbst ist äußerst
ungewöhnlich denn er dreht sich für
einen brocken dieser größe ziemlich
schnell für rechnung zufolge dreht er
sich in lediglich zwei stunden und 45
minuten einmal um seine achse und diese
schnelle rotation hat folgen so hat sich
der aktion bereits vorformen denn die
fliehkraft hat dafür gesorgt dass sein
äquator nach außen gezogen wird und so
sieht er aus als würde er von oben und
unten zusammengedrückt werden ähnlich
wie es auch bei dem hast du
der fall ist ein wenig erinnert seine
ganze form an einem wahllos sein
kleinerer begleiter dagegen ähnelt eher
einer erdnuss astronomie teams gehen
zudem davon aus dass der arzt selbst
wohl aus er porösem material besteht
klar ist das weltraum brocken aller art
immer mal wieder an der erde vorbeirasen
und zwar oft genug auch ohne das wäre es
im vorfeld bemerken doch das ist bei
1999 kw 4 anders denn bei ihm handelt es
sich um den größten brocken der der erde
bis zum jahr 2027 so nahe kommen
berechnungen zufolge wird er in einer
entfernung von nur 0,03 464
astronomischen einheiten an der erde
vorbei ziehen umgerechnet entspricht das
rund fünf millionen 182.000 70
kilometern um es noch deutlicher zu
machen diese abstand entspricht der 13,5
fachen entfernung unseres mondes zur
erde
so kann man für sonntag wohl entwarnung
geben denn die analysen seiner
derzeitigen bahn- legen nahe dass der
asteroid in den kommenden 1000 jahren
nicht mit der erde kollidieren wird
einen crash halten fachleute sogar für
ziemlich ausgeschlossen dennoch ist auch
klar dass seine schnelle rotation
gewisse risiken birgt denn dadurch
besteht die gefahr dass der brocken
instabil wird und zerbricht trümmerteile
könnten dann im fall der fälle die
gefahr für die erde erhöhen dennoch das
genaue beobachten solche objekte wie
1999 kwp es enorm wichtig um zum einen
ihre zusammensetzung und ihr verhalten
im detail zu verstehen aber auch
spannende erkenntnisse zur entwicklung
des sonnensystems sind dadurch möglich
zum anderen haben wir nur so eine chance
die erde zu schützen und so werden am
sonntag beispielsweise das radioteleskop
des arecibo observatoriums in puerto
rico am start sein genauso wie das 70
meter radioteleskop im goldstone
observatorium in kalifornien sie sollen
nicht nur die oberflächeneigenschaften
des asteroiden sondern auch seine
rotation periode noch genauer analysiert
werden zudem steht 1999 kw 4 auch im
mittelpunkt einer pavillon an kampagnen
das steht für international s rl holding
network und hat sich zum ziel gesetzt
potenziell gefährliche asteroiden zu
charakterisieren
und die erde auf solch eine bedrohung
vorzubereiten 1999 kw 4 dient hier als
übung um eine sogenannte beobachtungs
kette zu testen diese würde tatsächlich
ausgelöst werden wenn die
wahrscheinlichkeit hoch ist dass ein
ähnliches objekt auf der erde
einschlagen wird fest steht jedenfalls
schon jetzt 2036 wurde 1999 kw 4 wieder
nahe kommen aktuellen berechnungen gehen
dann von einer entfernung von nur noch
0,016 astronomischen einheiten aus das
sind dann wirklich nur noch ganz wenige
kilometer um ganz genau zu sein
zwei millionen 393 1565 also eben
einfach erklärt draufklicken anschauen
und raumzeit block der zukunft
abonnieren bis dann bleibt dran